what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
hair and I'm John back at it with
another hot trailer this week into the
spider-verse
I am thinking of actually buying the 31
issue series and reading it before the
movie like I did with some compost this
year I also know pretty good amount
about the Miles Morales before we do
that page of the day shout out for a man
named Austin Moore Austin looked up your
name today
it means magic dignity or that venerable
venerable the venerable venerable
venereal disease venereal disease what
does that word mean John you know your
distinguished certain amount of
respectability and importance oh well if
that was true you would have finished
that short film by now that I did the
voice-over work for you want that I
spent hours prepping a character for and
you still haven't put it together it's
been months buddy how long does it take
to assemble a masterpiece animation I
heard all those Disney films were
cranked out in like a month what's
taking you so long and it's a shadow
let's let's get to this now awesome take
your time buddy
[Music]
[Music]
easily dad walking would have been fine
news spider-man saves the day again
spider-man this guy swings in once a day
zip zap zop Nancy don't cops run red
lights well some do but uh not your day
yeah there's another universe
sounds like yours but it's not my name
is Miles Morales
[Music]
[Music]
steal or just came out of you have money
right I'm not very liquid right now
think you're gonna be a bad teacher you
have to think about saving one person
don't do it like me like you Brookwood
style hood
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
looks great yeah I think in the comics
how it goes down is Miles Morales he
gets these powers
spider-man's killed by Goblin yeah and
he witnesses that and which inspires him
to become spider-man dating in and for a
while is gonna have web shooters and
stuff I like this approach of him
actually being trained by Peter Parker
and I think a lot of the part of why
they might have switched it up a
marketing purposes be you know you get
strained by like Captain America the
Congress which belongs to a different
property at the moment you know and they
have a change of stuff around and
they're calling this into the
spider-verse but what I liked about this
marketing so far is that it's still
primarily sticking to [ __ ] Rallos
origin they hint at the end that there's
gonna be other Spider characters in here
cuz in the spider-verse comic book
there's a lot of spiders and a lot of
different types of Spider Man so to keep
this contained o instead of like
overwhelming your mind it's cool at the
marketing or at least it seems like even
the movie itself will primarily still
stick to a mozzarella's tale and maybe
they're planning on franchising out the
spider verse so yeah I gotta imagine
that franchise is what they have in mind
and at least for the terms of this
trailer to have miles being trained by
Peter it as the focus is really cool and
then to get that sting with spider-gwen
at the end I think is the right amount
of overhead the animation I know they
were talking about they wanted to have
something that felt really handcrafted
they wanted to kind of mix computer with
line drawings and dot coloring and I
chose yeah it really does look like a
perfect blend of 3d and comic book
animation come to life and like to see
them kind of innovate with the form as
well as you know bringing this story to
life is really cool and the look of
ultimate Green Goblin others crazy
it looks insane Miles Morales his dad
seems like such a charming element to it
this thing looks like it has a lot of
heart and a world where you got like
three spider-man franchises at this
point we're still getting live action
spider-man movies this does feel
refreshing and different as well
Myles his dad it is in the comics he
doesn't like superheroes and they hint
at that here spider-man this guy swings
in once the days it steps off man and
there's one moment here where at least
the way the trailer cuts it where the
doors dad goes hands up and then Myles
has to deal with like oh no I got to get
away from my book my pops oh you know
that's gonna be a detention yeah that
sounds I feel like that's a pretty
intense thing to have where the main
character's father is hunting him down
as well and the other part they also
show hear what he says hands up and then
he goes into camouflage mode which is a
unique power to Miles Morales cuz he got
bit by a slightly different spider or
something spider infected with Peters
blood I think it's gonna be cool to see
the mentorship happening where because
Peters also telling him don't do my
thing don't do it like me do it like you
do your thing so we're gonna see this
guy transition it's like setting up to
get a completely different kind of
spider-man in terms or you get a hint at
the new powers but you're also gonna get
a hint to the new style because he
because even he's from Brooklyn I
suppose you're gonna be like a new kind
of attitude as opposed to the Queen's
attitude of New York I don't really know
the difference is I'm not from New York
totally imagine there's a slight
difference in attitude there and I think
at 1:43 here you see character and
purple who looks like the Prowler which
is aaron davis aaron davis is actually
miles morales is uncle who is a
contribution to how miles actually gets
his abilities and aaron davis played by
Donald Glover in the live-action film
spider-man homecomings that's cool there
we're getting in there and it's like I
think for Maz Morales a story you
definitely need the Prowler in here oh
yeah one especially like already having
the tension coming from his dad you know
to have like an actual villain in his
own
gotta be a huge challenge for a
character like but yeah the movie looks
really cool the movie looks really fun
I'm sure fans Miles Morales are really
happy this is coming to life all right
guys well what do you guys think of this
into the spider-verse trailer what main
spider-man do you want to see in here
the audio of TV is one I'm sure that
would be cool you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons
don't really work and you can check us
out on patreon full a TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is newzik video coverage love
to have you become a patron eject today
people